what do you think about
prioritizing um career job degrees over
a relationship children and family um no
I'm more like oldfashioned and know like
I would have been a stay-at home mom
with no job and just look cute all the
time and gone to the gym get my nails
done and done all that I can marry
somebody we're working towards that
we're
working but you're not though hold on
but you're not let's catch that real
quick no I'm gonna I want to be like a
St whole mom with like a PhD you know
what I
mean how do those two things reconcile
themselves I know because those are
those are probably complete those are
opposite sides of that Spectrum yeah I
mean I think the bachelor's degree and I
was like that's all I need done I don't
want to ever go to school ever again and
I was done I grew up with a single mom
so I kind of have a different
perspective on prioritizing a career um
just seeing my Mom struggle financially
growing up I just wanted that ability
and that that I could always lean back
on and if I do happen to find somebody
that you know that could make me stay at
home of course like maybe down the line
I would love to have kids and be able to
do that but right now I just feel like
that career was just so important you
have an awesome career that you can go
anywhere in the country so that's and do
travel nursing exactly and I big Bank do
travel nursing but I think but what what
I think a lot of times women don't
understand when they talk about these
kinds of things and what sometimes and I
think a lot of people aren't honest with
them and they have these conversations
is that
the higher you climb on the
socioeconomic scale the higher your
degree it's there's an inverse
relationship between the number of men
that you're going to want to be attract
that you're going to be attracted to and
that are going to be at your standards
the higher you climb it's the Absol it's
it's the universe for men the higher men
the more money men make better educated
they are um you know higher their
climbing on the socio economic leate
their options expand but for women
because the way women generally date
across and mostly up that pool will get
ever smaller so I mean if you're a PhD
making 250k plus 500k a year you're
going to want at least somebody we hear
this a lot right I want somebody On My
Level well the higher your level goes
the higher that a guy is gonna have to
be on that level and so your options and
gu you want is GNA be ever ever ever
smaller when women say on On My Level
what they mean is above my level so if
you're in nursing making six figures
you're you're going to go for a doctor
that's making more than that or somebody
in a equivalent or higher status type of
career right I'm not gonna lie that I've
noticed that this past year for sure no
yeah me too I think you know and that's
why when like we I meet a guy that I do
consider someone who's like on the same
scale as me I like grab on to them
because even finding the bare minimum
like good manners um knows how to take
you on a date knows how to communicate
with you effectively is like as hard as
it is and then trying to find someone
who also has a good career and has a
good head on their shoulders it's just
like so I can only imagine that it gets
worse and worse and I feel like every
year these men get you know they find a
girlfriend and they got they get Mar you
know what I mean so the dating pool just
gets smaller and smaller for us you were
you were talking about the career
Pursuit um not wanting to be serious
with a guy um a nurse makes what like
about 100
150,000 depending on where you live okay
usually like new like new grads make
anywhere from like 80 to 90 just
depending on where you live and over
time as well you can make your six
figures definitely we only work three
days you pick up one to two extra shifts
you're making six figures okay so let me
ask you this question if you had the
option of Life a which is on the path
that you're on right now you're going to
make1 $150,000 a year you work three
days a week the rest of time you're free
to travel take photographs you know do
all the cool stuff that you like to do
share sh you know share your life on
social media or path B is um finding a
guy that you find equally as attractive
maybe even more who's uh wealthy and I'm
not talking about you know making the
same amount of money as you I'm talking
about making a lot more money than you
can I say now pardon me can I say B
option b now I I haven't finished even
telling you what option b is completion
but option b is that like you just want
a guy that's good-look that makes a lot
more money right yeah
and then he can just retire you you can
stay home more money I'm just saying
would you would you want to be retired
and stay home and have babies or would
you want to continue on with your career
I still want to work till what age until
I retire with a good retirement funding
okay so you wouldn't want to have kids
then I do want to have kids well how are
you going to balance a guy a career
children family so in so I have to get
my ICU Critical Care hours done and
that's going take at least one year and
I can apply to anesthesiology schools
um in about a year after those hours are
complete with that schedule they have so
much time off and I feel like I will be
able to balance with being an
anesthesiologist it is a very rigorous
career don't get me wrong but there is a
lot of time with the hospital that they
give you time off when you are pregnant
and I feel like they they can balance
your family life there's so many doctors
that I know that have multiple kids and
they have so like months of vacation
time paid like I think it's just a good
option it's you me doctors we're talking
about men though right we talking about
men having yeah which which are
generally men right so I mean they're
generally men are not the ones that are
staying home taking care of children you
know you don't really have stay-at home
dads no I have lot of Nur like not
nurses ER doctors that are beautiful
women that have kids and they bring them
into the like er all the time and I I I
still think that they have a really good
balance with you know with their life
they can be done what sort of what sort
of complaints do you hear from these
older women that have beautiful children
in ER like what do they what are their
lives like like what do you hear about
them I really don't hear any complaints
everything's perfect for them I hear
them going out voting every weekend with
their husband and their kids on the
weekend and I'm like I want that you
know okay and their and their husbands
do what like are they medical
professionals as well yeah there was one
doctor that I work with they both work
you you know they're both doctors and
okay I don't know what the other husband
does that I know so on on option b i
described hot dude and then I got to
wealthy and successful and you stopped
me there and you're like just give me
option b why did you stop there like why
does he just have to be hot and
successful hot and Rich it's not even
that he has to have money honestly um I
but you stop me on B when I got to money
attractive that's where I'm going to
stop you at because I have no they're
both equally attractive I'm just saying
like be is more successful has a lot
more money I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out